ah
so what what is some of your favorite to
the test today and there are a lot of
favorites our next challenge is a
culinary one
please welcome dietitian Abby sharp here
she
okay your Julie challenge a B of a Jan
to make that three budget-friendly
dinners for a family of four using the
same three staples and those tables are
canned beans for one chicken for another
chicken thighs and dried pasta okay it
is presentation time we do we're not
gonna make them do it in 20 minutes okay
so what we decided to do was whoever
made the most inexpensive meal wins what
did you make with the canned beans so
for the beans I thought instead of your
typical bean salad or tacos sloppy joe
cuz everyone loves a good yeah so that's
the great pantry staple kind of recipe
it's just got canned tomatoes some
carrots and celery lots of spices some
red wine vinegar and of course our
signature beans I'm piling this onto a
whole-wheat bun and for our vegetable I
discovered when I was in the grocery
store that cabbage is like the cheapest
vegetable you can buy a whole head of
cabbage for just over two dollars and it
will feed an army of people right so
basically I've just made a little
dressing of some apple cider vinegar
vegetable oil a little salt pepper and
some sugar we've got our cabbage right
in here I am some shredded carrots which
is also a very inexpensive vegetable so
you can get your veggies in your fresh
your fresh vegetables in okay still be
very budget-conscious I'll save it Jay
what did you make with your canned beans
I made trees oh and black bean taco Oh
heads let me tell you happy you go to
the fanciest restaurants and they have
tacos on their menu okay
so Teresa is a really popular Spanish
sausage if you went to the grocery store
and bought it off the shelf it would be
really expensive
so all I did was I said lean ground pork
yeah as his wives added spices and a
little bit of vinegar to it let it sit
over in the overnight and the
refrigerator in there like yeah right
you have to let it marinate no then I
let sauteed it up with some onions
during my can of black beans and this is
a beautiful avocado crema and it's so
simple all it is is avocado lime juice a
little bit of salt and water and whizz
it up and it gets this beautiful fluffy
texture it's really really yummy and
then garnish some sliced radishes and
cilantro okay now here's that that looks
fantastic let's take a final shot of
abby's don't live stage for so good
there was some choco trash-talk
happening but let's see whose bean dish
is cheaper okay let's find out okay
Abbey dish per serving on this one is a
dollar thirty one
the Jagdish perserving is what did you
make with your chicken thighs my dear it
smells so again I wanted to get that
nutrition in lots of vegetables right
we're starting with polenta and a lot of
fine-dining restaurants will really
judge they're soaked with lots of butter
and cream and fun Parmesan cheese but to
cut calories in cash I discovered a
little trick where if you use just a few
tablespoons of evaporated skim milk and
you still get that same creamy concealer
okay good
so when with the chicken thighs always
buy them with the skin on because I know
we're all busy people but we all have
time to rip skin off chicken and so
we've got lots of veggies in here you
can use whatever is on season we've got
some zucchini and tomatoes and carrots
and I was pretty good and how you gonna
chop it up oh yeah so we got some
parsley okay there you doing everybody
what do you think of a chicken thighs
for BJP's I'm going to Morocco for this
one with Moroccan chicken tagine over
couscous and couscous is a really
inexpensive grain yeah I just cooked it
with a little bit of water and salt you
don't need to eat and add anything else
because all the flavor is coming from
the Taji uh-huh for the tagine my tip
here is with the chicken thighs what you
want to do is you want to sear them off
so in this tagine I have a little bit of
butternut squash some olives it's really
festive big on flavor because I used a
lot of spices that's looks to
socialisation flavor payoff there this
segment is making Maryland very hungry
and okay let's just prices right now
that looks delicious and a little bit of
white on top a little bit of cilantro a
little bit cilantro there you go thank
you for Junior okay
George's first serving how much it cost
two dollars and eight cents wha
the janitor new top top price for
serving
next one what can you do so right now
it's coresight okay next one is oh gosh
what you can make with pasta a people
did you make with pasta well rather than
the traditional Italian cuisine I
thought we'd do an Asian stir-fry we'd
switch things up Blanca and what I did
was I also stretched our pasta by
getting lots more veggies in there so
I'm cutting down on carbs and calories
as well I've added some cabbage so that
leftover cabbage because we've got a
whole head to use either and recei
spiralized carrot in there so that's our
beautiful veg action did you do that oh
yeah there we go and so rather than a
really expensive Asian sauce has sesame
oil and poison sauce
I just basically put one together using
chicken stock soy sauce little grams
sugar some hot chili flakes and rice
wine vinegar we all have that kind of
stuff on hand and then for protein I
think a lot of people forget that we all
have eggs in the fridge and eggs are a
great inexpensive source of provide you
that all the time just whip that up at
you know for dinner so then we've got
some green onions here in a little
peanut for crabby chard you have an egg
when you could have shrimp Oh what did
you do with your table stuff the lemony
shrimp linguini here so all it is is a
little bit of garlic sautéed up with
some shrimp very simple zucchini and a
great tip is to stretch out your protein
add a lot of vegetables and so I cooked
up a little bit of pasta here yeah we're
gonna throw all of this in nice and
light and then to finish it off if your
pass is looking a little dry add a
little bit of the pasta water because it
had some starch to it and it'll help
thicken the sauce okay and then we have
some lemon juice and lemon zest
so instead of all of those cheeses and a
little bit of flat-leaf parsley for
freshness give that a nice toss like how
good does that look you guys yeah and
you know
both of you on a on a on a fish pasta
anything with fish and I never put
cheese in it it's yeah I told you that I
don't that's wrong it's not wrong but
it's not what you should oh yeah come on
come on there you go survey how much was
yours per serving
I'd like to thank my mother hey that's
enough thanks to surveys that's enough
that's enough we're not able to do the
crawl at the Oscars said thanks to
Sobeys guess what everybody you're all
going to get a $100 gift card
thanks to the presentation time for a
leave LG in Nashua Asik when they reveal
their own uniquely stout room that's up
next